[Música]
nosotros tengan todos ustedes de verdad
es un privilegio estar aquí hace rato me
preguntaban tú qué estás tan
acostumbrado a estar delante del público
sí pero para que me vean tocar no para
que me oigan hablaba entonces siempre
una novedad hacia este tipo de cosas
pero me entusiasman profundamente porque
yo quiero practicar les de algo
extraordinario que ha pasado en esta
ciudad y quería explicarles cómo fue que
pasó hace 10 años precisamente un grupo
de personas ahora las llamo visionarios
en aquella época los llamaban locos
decidieron creer en ustedes
yo me encontraba fuera de mexico como
muchos de los que andan por aquí y
llegar a mexico diciendo por qué no
pasan ciertas cosas que yo he visto en
otros lados porque la gente no vive o no
exige vivir de otra forma yo soy músico
y veía en el extranjero que pasaban
conciertos maravillosos que pasaban
espectáculos de teatro increíbles pero
llegué y me dijeron una cosa que me puso
muy triste te lo tengo que decir ustedes
los tolucos
son fríos
vamos a hacer una nueva orquesta como
creéis nadie va a ir
no es necesario para que a nadie le
gusta la música
y dije no es cierto porque de todas las
personas que yo conozco y además podría
hacer una encuesta en ese momento decir
levanten la mano a que no le gusta la
música estoy seguro que nadie la
levantaría porque la música es una parte
de nosotros es una parte de ustedes yo
decía regreso a mi casa
y me gustaría que las cosas fueran
distintas y fue así como se conformó un
grupo como ya les dije de locos pero
sobre todo de tercos que empezaron a
soñar a pensar distinto
y dije un día vamos a hacer una
temporada de ballet
para niños al máximo que he visto yo de
ballet quizás habrá sido algo la tele
primera temporada de ballet que hasta
hoy repetimos fue tan exitosa que
tuvimos que crear dos funciones
y entonces se acercaba a los medios que
andan por ahí atrás que siempre me andan
correteando y les me decían que pasó
desde no más bien dígame qué pasó
ustedes porque me dicen que no va a
venir nadie no que los productos eran
fríos
pasó el tiempo y decidimos con estas
personas extraordinarias diseñar
proyectos distintos lo primero que
hicimos y fue este recinto y me emociona
porque aquí fue
y vamos a hacer el primer concierto de
música de películas casi de la historia
de mexico saben cuántas personas se
quedaron afuera de este teatro así como
están ustedes más de 2000 personas y me
da pena decirlo pero también un poco de
vanidad ten que decirlo al otro día
salió en el metro este periódico con
todo respeto pues un poco el macabro
una nota que decía así tal cual al lado
de un señor que desgraciadamente ya no
está con nosotros
salimos nosotros nuestra claro que está
donde decía porque estaba rota y crea
caos en el entonces nuncio y csc y
entonces me di cuenta que estaba pasando
algo en la ciudad que algo había se
había estaba cambiando pero porque
estaba cambiando
yo les quiero hacer una pregunta a todos
ustedes hoy escogí este cuadro
maravilloso que pueden ver aquí que en
realidad es una litografía de uno de los
grandes litógrafos de todos los tiempos
que se llama el ser si eres una persona
rara
un loco un artista entonces si usted ve
en esa pintura y se meten de la pintura
no habrá salir de este círculo que un
poco me ha presiona
si empiezan a ver desde la izquierda no
quiero que lo vean con atención como
dice sea les pero van a ir surgiendo
muchas figuras que se van a ir
transformando en otras cosas y después
no sé por qué una abeja se transformó en
él
en un pescado pero después si seguimos
el eje de la pintura van a ver que en el
extremo izquierdo ese pescado se
transforma en otra cosa y después
geométricamente se transforma en una
ciudad
y eso qué tiene que ver con lo que estoy
diciendo yo
pues a lo mejor no tiene nada que ver
pero me gustaba mucho el cuadro que
quería enseñar
es el pensamiento divergente
qué es pensar distinto
ustedes han puesto a pensar por ejemplo
para un artista en donde empieza la obra
de arte
y cómo acaba la obra de arte
eso se preguntaba eso en este cuadro
cuando nosotros vamos a la escuela pues
nosotros nos enseñan a ir por un camino
balbás caminando
te dicen terminaste la primaria siguen
las secundarias
yo acabé la secundaria
la prepa
si no lo haces te señala no no a ver
aquí hay muchos papás dijo ponte
estudiar la prepa
y papá quiero ser músico ay por dios
vete a estudiar la facultad
tráeme una carrera
papá pero es que quiero ser actor
así somos
porque seguimos el mismo camino porque a
veces pensamos que seguir el mismo
camino nos va a llegar a una meta segura
cierto no
pero ayer no
ayer os quiere enseñar el pensamiento
divergente
dónde empieza la idea
donde nace la obra de arte
en donde nace lo distinto entonces el
ser dice nace una especie de avispero y
uno pensaría que el cuadro terminaría
precisamente en un maravilloso cuadro
lleno de avispas pero que quieren que
pasa
el divergente las personas que piensan
distinto
en el momento en que sale del avispero
la avispa ya no es tan avispa resulta
que se transformó como una especie de
mariposa y al final de esa parte del
cuadro ya ni siquiera es mariposa ya es
un pescado
pero por qué el divergente busca otro
tipo de realidad
porque la obra de arte lo que nace de
nuestras cabezas se tiene que
transformar en una cosa distinta para
obtener una cosa distinta
de hecho una persona con pensamiento
divergente generalmente no espera un
resultado enfrenta a la divergencia
hasta de manera desordenada con muchas
ideas
nosotros ahí en la orquesta filarmónica
es toluca cuando nos sentamos a trabajar
en nuestra mesa de trabajo yo sé que a
lo mejor te tienen ideas así como
extravagantes así como del artista han
de pensar el maestro urban y su gente
han de estar nos tumbados en unos sofás
viendo el techo esperando a ver si baja
la inspiración así como una especie de
rayo de luz yo no pero no lo interesante
de la divergencia es que todas esas
personas increíbles que hacen parte del
staff tienen miles de ideas y no importa
fíjense qué interesante no importan que
sean distintas porque la diferencia de
las ideas es lo que hará que uno de los
proyectos en la orquesta por ejemplo se
distingue un ejemplo hace unos meses
hicimos un maravilloso concierto que ni
estaba planeado para empezar la
divergencia estaba yo ahí sentado en un
café y de repente porque no haces un
concierto de game of thrones
y de skate
es una serie de famosa web
vamos todos para allá
quiero hacer un concierto de una serie
de que van a investigar todos
y todos van a aportar algo yo me
comprometo a ver la serie
y entonces empezamos a trabajar a crear
imagínense la locura de todos y el
frenesí empezaba a transformarse no solo
del pescado
a un cierto punto al maestro urban
empieza a tocar un vídeo maravilloso y
el maestro ni yo lo sabía cuando cuando
tuve sed además creo hoy que me
arrepiento porque alguien me dijo tienes
que entrar a caballo y del rey de la
noche en el teatro morelos a caballo si
eso va a ser un éxito
pues no sé si fue ridículo prende a
caballo
con una máscara en medio del humo en
medio de gritos parecía yo hasta el
instante que entra el estadio ya sean
timón y todavía no es una cosa
interesante este tipo de ideas y de
locuras llevó a un fenómeno a la
orquesta a otro nivel saben cuántas
personas se quedaron fuera del teatro
morelos ese día más de 1500 personas
pero porque la gente
se motiva de esa manera para ir a ver un
espectáculo de música
porque es distinto
la divergencia es una de las cosas más
fascinantes del mundo y podemos
construir ciudades maravillosas las
ciudades más hermosas del mundo son
precisamente donde los seres divergentes
más extraordinarios han nacido piensen
por ejemplo en florencia
piensen de leonardo
pinchen en miguel ángel
yo quiero hoy que se vayan con una
reflexión cuantas veces ustedes son
capaces de pensar de otra forma
porque ellos los divergentes que están
aquí sentados los que siempre pensaron
que las cosas podían ser
se opusieron a muchas cosas tristán te
voy a decir algunos ejemplos se ponía
enfrente de la portería y para poderlos
hacer campeones tenía que engañar al
otro para tirarse del otro lado pensando
y poder hacer el milagro una persona
normal esperaré hasta el último momento
pero seguramente con su creatividad
este futbolística hacia una cosa
distinta y al final para un penalti
nosotros nos íbamos a colom a festejar
es la verdad es cierto es cierto el
divergente no sigue un camino quién iba
a pensar que aquí en toluca y vamos a
tener videojuegos
es una locura no sin embargo hay un ser
divergente ahí y gracias a él ahora nos
abre la mente
es toluca
campeones de tap dijo que es pero sin
embargo hay una persona que dice esto es
mi vida
ellos los divergentes
las personas que cuidan con amor el
volcán el teporingo
las personas que con ternura han ido
este año gran día con día un sombrero
porque nos
esto es un conmovedor porque es nuestra
identidad
y con amor con talento lo anuda ella es
divergente por favor
no se rindan
no dejen de luchar
porque si ustedes no se rinden ellos
tampoco lo harán muchas gracias
[Aplausos]